I reject nation Greg Alba here John over
here John what time is it
sure well twelve can you see the time
and for us the bumblebee trailer has
dropped oh boy we're gonna both about to
go to bed so you catch it in the morning
oh boy but that's change plans but we're
still gonna publish this around 6 to 7
a.m. somewhere there just because of the
I don't know algorithm stuff and it
makes more sense according to everyone
who helps us out do this yeah no one's
up at midnight for this so yeah let's
let's just see what the hives of boughs
quit beating around the bush here I'm
curious because is the first one not
directed by Michael Bay so let's see if
it feels or looks any different let's do
that yeah go to Johnson
okay
is that birdie back yeah for the first
one okay
[Music]
Iron Giant yeah okay
Wow me
this kind of does have an Iron Giant
vibe yeah
[Music]
cool
[Music]
Wow
you've got people out there who need you
this is why you're here be
Noby music can help you say what you're
feeling try this
[Music]
we just got rickrolled wow that looks
different I know I delightfully
different this does not feel like that
case because every Transformers trailer
feels like another cool-looking Michael
Bay trailer for a Transformers movie
this feels like a different movie look
at his heart this feels like an iron jaw
and this guy has an animation background
I was directed to coupon the two strings
and he's worked on like ParaNorman a
bunch of other animated stuff compared
to Iron Giant makes actually a lot of
sense in this department of this
teenager the friending this mysterious
alien giant robot yeah and it looks like
the centerpiece of it is the bond
between this girl and him Anna the
military's coming out surprising this
trip is not capitalizing on like action
or cool shots it seemed like it was
about its heart and its tone and spirit
which is a delight I'm really hoping the
film sticks to that that looked unique
didn't feel like I was watching a
Transformers trailer pushes I don't love
Transformers movies I won't begrudge
them wanting to be what they are but you
know coming from wildly popular line of
toys and cartoons it seems cool to have
something in the Transformers universe
that would be more accessible for kids
but also like I got excited watching
this trailer like I think that element
of heart capitalizes on something that
is kind of the best part of nostalgia
for me too because this does remind me
of something older but it's about that
bond you know between a kid and a robot
or something like that you know yeah it
actually looks like it could be kind of
magical and it seems like they might
have got the right guy to do it there's
potential for them to actually get this
right is what this trailer kinda game it
does it feels like more than just hey
bumblebee origins it feels like they're
telling a completely different kind of
movie and I like the cinematography to
it a part of me can't help but just sort
of compare my the images to what I would
normally see from five Michael Bay
movies yeah this feels like a refreshing
quality and it feels like a life about
it trying to be cool finale yeah exactly
feel like it feels like it'll be maybe
temper
even or maybe actually like I said I
don't know just like ya have a heart of
some kind because I feel like in the
actual Michael Bay Transformers films
every shot is cranked up - yeah bro this
is so cool yeah once you get that out of
the way like there could be something
both really fun but also action-packed
cuz we saw a pretty sinister looking
evil transformer - I'm sure like a
villain will come in here but it this
really does have Iron Giant vibes yeah
yeah yeah it just feels like a
Transformers movie that happens to start
bumblebee at least from this I'm
definitely interested it's hard after
having a sour taste of the Transformers
movies to go I'm completely sold but for
what I got here I found myself genuinely
smiling throughout ya and at a nice like
magical way where I wasn't associating
like a bumblebee Optimus Prime I was
just looking at this machine story and
human story this feels like this could
be something special I mean in
transformer 7 got cancelled maybe this
is what they need and they could go in a
better direction just alright formers
trailer that didn't make me think about
this trailer I mean I hope people are
liking this I mean right now as we're
watching this it has 11,000 views 1.3 K
like alright guys well you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification belcan subscribe buttons
don't really do the job man check us on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is love to have you become a
patron eject today yes ma'am